[Music]
n
la
[Music]
hello hello and welcome I got the thumbs
up so it is time to open up the doors to
daily with Doc hello and welcome to
daily with Doc my name is Rebecca Dukes
known by my friends as Becca and I will
be your host for the next 50 minutes of
empowering information that empowers you
as an individual folks we are empowered
in individuals please don't ever forget
that but we Empower you with information
that you can put in your toolbox to be
able to use on your own as and be we're
a resource folks we're a resource to an
amazing community of health-minded
Wellness minded people that are coaching
others to Better Health so if you are
either healthy and want to stay healthy
which is the easy actually or you are
looking for a better health Journey
because you're not quite wanting to be
where you want to be you are in the
right place so make sure that you
remember who shared this program with
you and then afterwards don't forget to
get back with them and tell them thank
you for sharing this information with
you today so for those of you are here
live with us in the zoom room you are
more than welcome to raise your hand and
ask questions Dr wallik is going to be
doing a opening monologue sharing some
exciting information that's going on
that he is uh in the middle of or
leading or yeah yeah he's just the man
on top guys um he's going to be sharing
some information on that and then we're
g to go into questions and answers so
the people who are here live with us in
the zoom room make sure that you have
that chat option open because our
amazing Marilyn is an incredible typist
and she's going to be doing dictation
and making notes throughout and so is I
believe um Phyllis is going to be adding
to that as well so you do not want to
miss that chat now if you're not here
live with us and you would like to be
you are welcome to join us on daily with
Doc
zoom.com so that is a live Zoom that
happens from 12 to 12:5
PM Pacific Time Monday through
Friday almost every week of the year
we're taking a little bit of time off
here and there but for the most part we
are here so if you are watching a replay
or watching us live and you would like
to join us live then go ahead and jump
on over to daily withc
zoom.com this program is sponsored by
daily withth
do.com so you will be able to find
replays on our website but you can also
find them on our YouTube channels we are
critical Health news on YouTube and
Rumble we're critical Health on Facebook
and we are daily with Doc on almost
everything else so if you're on a
platform look us up daily with Doc find
us like us follow us share us whatever
it takes or whatever is available let's
make sure that people understand how
empowered they really are and what they
can do on their own through
intentional practices folks intentional
it's not just what we don't put in our
mouth but it's what we do put in our
mouth what we have in our environments
what we put on our skin it all matters
now the FDA does require us to let you
know that this program is for
informational purposes only on the
importance of supplementation and
nutrition the doctor that we have with
us he actually sued the FDA so that we
could say more of the truth about how
important nutrition is so important that
he took it upon himself he and his legal
team he paid to sue the FDA and make
sure that those needed essential
nutrients are in our BAS baby formulas
so we can have healthier
babies because if you have healthier
babies that just leads into healthier
teens healthier adults healthier
seniors folks we cannot cannot Overlook
the importance of nutrition even before
conception because that's where it all
starts with those cells coming together
continually creating if they don't have
the building blocks needed to create
healthy cells they're just not going to
be as healthy as they possibly can be so
with that being
said it is my honor and privilege oh one
more thing this program is not meant to
take the place of your primary care
physician and you should consult your
physician be before starting any dietary
program including drinking water so
without further Ado let's bring on with
as Dr Joel wallik his Bachelor of
Science in agriculture and a doctorate
of veterinary
medicine three postdoctorates in
pathology for those of you who don't
know what that is he cut everything up
he diagnosed it I mean he he analyzed it
he put it into charts he put it into
books and even has one of his books the
diseases of exotic animals held as a
national treasure in the Smithsonian
Museum and if that was not enough after
finding cause cure prevention of a few
different diseases and he posted them
and they were published he became a
naturopathic physician but he didn't get
recognized for those accomplishments
until after he became a natural a
naturopathic physician so there's a lot
of stuff going on Dr W like that we're
not going to wait that many years before
you get recognized on why don't should
tell us all about it okay well it's very
exciting and thank you I mean we've been
working like crazy I know I've been
working the last 78 hours and um
Rebecca's been
working 28 hours a minute okay I know
she's working hard all over the map and
so forth and we we've got this case
report that's been accepted for
publication for the Journal of our
health coaches and it's going to be
published before the end of this month
I'm very excited about this this is
going to get the information out at a
professional level that that's different
than people just talking about it okay
very very excited and that's what Cheryl
Morley and Paul Crow are the editors of
that very proud of them and so I'm
editor they're the co-founders of The
Institute Dr W I'm sorry they are the
co-founders of The Institute of holistic
health I'm the editor of the journal
well there you go
Chief like I wanted another title do
wck I have plenty so folks if you're
really good at editing and you want to
take on something like this and you want
to be part of the health coach course
just let me know reach out to me dawid
do.com use contact us send us an email
we're here for you go ahead Dr W okay so
I don't get this wrong I'm G to read
like two or three paragraphs here out
out of the front end of this case report
case reports are extremely valuable
on the history of medicine okay because
usually they fly in the face of what
everybody believes and they come out
with a case report showing that it's all
wrong and got to go a different
direction and um you know I I was a guy
who found the cause prevention cure of
cystic fibrosis it's supposed to be a
terrible genetic birth effect in humans
I'm the guy that found the cause pren
and cure of musy thank goodness Jerry
Lewis was still alive when we figured
that out and he knew that we had found
the cause prevention cure of must three
various kids very proud of that also
found the cause and prevention of sudden
a death syndrome doctors were saying
mothers were laying on their babies and
suffocating it was really just a simple
nutritional deficient disease so very
proud of those three things and you know
I never had one doctor ever call me or
write me or send me an email or anything
hey thanks wallik we really appreciate
what you're doing for the community I
didn't have one doctor after
brosus muscular in SN Med death syndrome
wiping them out didn't get one communic
from any medical doctors so that tells
you where they're coming from okay here
we go this is an abstract of of the um
um case report that's going into the
um uh journal for the uh health coaches
okay you see here the predicted course
of parkon disease is seven to 10 years
ending in death resulting in a gradual
Progressive collapse of the central
nervous system typical of a milting lot
of the white white um matter of the
brain including Tremors rigidity humming
balance problems balance issues each
year the United States now this is an
increase okay because I I was previously
giving out the numbers from 19 excuse me
2019 and Rebecca got the numbers from
2023 and so I was saying that there was
500,000 cases of of um Parkinson's East
constantly now there's 1 million cases
in 2023 Park I was saying there's 50,000
new cases every year diagnosed in
America no there's 90,000 new cases
diagnosed and 37,000 deaths okay from a
disease each year now the
background this this case report is this
75y old female meline o I can't give her
last name yet 175 pounds and she is
diagnosed with the classic symptoms of
Parkinson disease in 2012 by The Rush
University Medical Center in ill Chicago
Illinois very famous medical school okay
and Clinic the patient was given an
annual physical every year for 11 years
every year for 11 years with A
continuous confirmation of symptoms of
parking disease and the treatment using
Pharmaceuticals okay here we go the
patient was started on the wallik
recommended
formulations okay at the beginning of
this year the formula given to
meline included eliminating all the bad
foods you know no fried food no
processed meat and all that kind of
stuff which slowly destroy milin over
the white man of the brain um all that
and then um supplemented with a
foundation okay I got to switch Pages
here supplement of foundation of
targeted approach using the formulas
recommended by me Dr wallik okay um now
now here's the results after two and a
half months just two and a half months
75 days on my program versus 11 years on
their
program meline went to her scheduled
annual physical be the 12th physical in
12 years determined to be free from all
the park disease symptoms after 11 years
of positive annual reports and getting
worth conclusion here it is it appears
that by providing an adequate diet okay
including Good Foods eliminating bad
foods and supp ING with the known
required nutrients to support maintain
repair myin the brain and spinal cord
present reverse all of the dementing
diseases holy moly and of course par dis
was diagnosed the first in
1817 and there's there's a whole thing
here of references and and stuff at the
back of this article so that'll be part
of the publication and then one other
piece let's see here
this is I don't know how this is going
to be used maybe help the the authors or
not the authors but the editors new
study indicates Parkinson disease is 50%
more prevalent than previously thought
okay we went over that okay okay here we
go in addition the study looked at the
geographical um variation in diagnosis
and found a higher incidence of parkas
in certain areas of the United States in
the Midwest south as well as Southern
California and Southeast in Texas and
central Pennsylvania Florida okay the
critical finding um Builds on passwor
and updated estimates and of of
prevalence
of parkon now have to appreciate
nutritional minerals do not Ur in
uniform blanket around the C of the
earth they C in veins like gold and
silver so you can be eating the exact
same recipe as somebody who's two
counties over next state up and eating
the same exact recip cook the exact same
way and you might be deficient in 25
minerals and they're getting a
deficiency of only one or three or maybe
no deficiencies okay because of what's
in the soil what is not in the
soil our big big hammer came down on us
um at three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 when Thomas
Edison pulled that switch on electricity
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years okay before the Old
Testament we had been using wood and
coal as fuel everybody's taking the wood
ashes and putting them in their Garden
using them as spice and and their food
same way with coal ashes now wood ashes
and coal ashes are 98% minerals only two
or 3% carbon at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
Thomas S pulled that switch and within
18 years by 1900 the turn of the 20th
century suddenly now we had 50 or more
new disease nobody ever seen before
they're all nutritional deficient
diseases because suddenly we didn't have
access to those minerals anymore because
we gave up the wood ashes and coal Ashes
to make electricity right we had
hydroelectric from from dams okay and we
had Sunshine electricity okay driving
turbines and everything but we gave up
all our minerals when we went to
electricity how much elect how much
minerals do you get when you use
electricity in your house you're plug in
the you plug in the the iron you plug in
the TV you plug in the um stove none and
so this is why we have all these
nutritional deficiencies is because we
gave up our historical source of
nutrition which the good lord gave us
and once we went to electricity that if
if they would have said okay now
everybody needs a supplement with 90
cents of nutrients to make up the
difference but they didn't do that they
just said ah just don't pay attention
that just nonsense just keep doing what
you're doing everything be fine okay it
was a big big big bad bad bad thing okay
and so now we actually have a book out
also um the um it has to do with um um
um Hell's Kitchen it's the book is
totally on the transition of wood and
coal as fuel to electricity and all the
diseases we've gotten since that
transition from wood and coal to
electricity so with that said I'm going
to turn that over to Rebecca because I'm
excited we are going to be helping so
many people and the team the young jvid
family is going to be the core of this
wonderful thing that's happening here
just like what happened with cystic ab
brosis muscularis and C death syndrome
this is going to be the big one because
now we have the internet back then the
internet was not a big thing and it was
easy for all the bad guys to control all
the information but now guess what
anybody can get the information out
there through the internet so over to
you Rebecca all right thank you so much
Dr wck yes we are able to use the
internet in a very big way with digital
files that um we get saved in so many
different places that if we get attacked
you know they can't attack everything
because they're not not all connected so
that's the nice thing about it and no
it's not going to get lost in the mail
and if it does we just resent it so
there's a lot of advantages to
technology Dr wck and I love that I'm
able to be on this end of it with you
and making sure that the information
does get out to the masses because it's
important folks you're not going to hear
a doctor tell you a whole protocol of
what to eat what not to eat what's to
supplement with and
why
okay when it comes to maintaining regain
or ha maintaining or regaining
Health they get educated in these great
colleges that are unfortunately
sponsored by a pharmaceutical industry
that wants to promote the use of
chemicals to mask
symptoms we're not into masking symptoms
we're looking at okay what's the
underlying cause and this is something
that Dr wallik has been doing doing for
at least six decades what was the
underlying
cause and then addressing what the
underlying cause was seeing if it worked
and it did and here we are today and
this is just the first of many many case
studies that I am working on and this is
going to be an amazing tool that we are
putting together for the Institute of H
Institute of holistic health health
coaches in this journal for them to be
able to use as another tool so folks if
you have an interest in health and you
would like to join us on this Crusade
and become a certified holistic health
coach you can go to Coach with Doc
that's coach withth
do.com get some more information about
the coaching program and get started um
because it goes through the four areas
of Health how they're affected by
nutritional deficiencies and then it
doesn't stop there it goes into
Solutions folks we can have all the
information in the world
on everything that's wrong with
everything but unless we have Solutions
on what needs to be done in order to
correct the problem you're not going to
make any
progress so let's make a massive impact
on progress to regaining the health for
a health
world and that's what I like about this
Dr well like we are in many countries we
are expanding to additional countries so
folks no matter where you are in this
world you have a place in being able to
be part of the Crusade that brings back
Wellness not managing sickness but
brings back and promotes Wellness
so we have lots of hands up Dr wck well
you get an A+ you did a great job of
explaining what's going on here and
again the whole idea is to get as many
people involved as possible to get this
information out there
because you know there's
only in the history there's only a dozen
times
when what should I say significant
discoveries were made that eliminated
diseases now Rebecca said it correctly
the medical system is designed to create
something that will relieve pain and
discomfort okay that's their main main
goal okay is to relieve pain and
discomfort um and so we're looking for
that also but also we want to add 25 to
50 healthful years to your life okay we
can do that you give your body what it
body can help
itself healthy years yes healthy years
absolutely not just not just extend
sickness but healthy
years that's that's what I'm most
passionate about Dr wellet because I was
in that state where I was too young to
feel as old as I did we getting all
those old people
diseases I was getting all those old
people diseases and I was diagnosed with
it at 30 and I
mean being able to see it on an MRI like
you promote all the time and having a
neurologist think he was coming into the
wrong room after looking at my reports
and
slides it explained why I felt so bad
why I hurt all the time why I was
getting compression
fractures but it still it didn't give me
any
solutions or an underlying cause so here
we've got a problem didn't know the
underlying cause and their only solution
was um a back surgery and pain meds I
didn't do both either I didn't do
either because I have an aunt that went
down that road
and like 27 28 surgeries later to fix
what the first one did the
damage I don't know how she still alive
but she went from 5 foot six beautiful
thin to barely able to stand up to 4
foot five I think is what it is um and
and constant Agony and pain so folks
don't go down that track give Dr wallik
days on his recommendations and program
before making any type of invasive
decisions we're all about
non-invasive so nutrition in the right
form and taking out those things that
are causing the damage in the first
place it's an easy step it's not simple
but it's easy and it takes mindset to be
able to make it happen and make it
happen most efficiently and it takes
somebody guiding you with the right
direction so that's that's one thing
that I love about the coaching program
Dr wallik is
because the the course goes through so
many different modules all the different
areas of health and it it goes not quite
into the anatomy as far as you know deep
like a doctor
would but the cause and effect of
nutrition and for me when I can see okay
you do this you get this effect you do
this hey there's a different
outcome that speaks louder than a book
this thick that tells me what's
connected to
what
so with that being said I'm going to get
off my soap boox and we're going to go
to the first hand that is up Dr wallik
and Steve go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with Dr
wallik oh he turned his camera
off hi Steve hello how are you fabulous
you're on live with Dr wck hello Dr wck
I'm years old M and uh I have some
issues I can't smell things although I
can taste pretty good I was hit by a
truck in
1991 head on while I was riding my
motorcycle and uh I sustained some very
severe injuries broken bones internal
bleeding uh concussion I was in the
hospital several
months and uh kman helped me to recover
good bit I'm working with the 90 for
life
now and uh I currently weigh 270 pounds
I was 420 pounds when I got out of my
wheelchair and I got out of my
wheelchair 10 years ago decided I was
not going to be in that
again so now I'm 270 and working on
getting down to
180 so uh I would like a little guidance
on what I can do 108 how tall are you
I'm six feet tall and 180 should be my
ID 180 I thought you said 108 sorry
about
that okay all right um how many times
you wake up at night to urinate once
three times five times depends usually
about two or three times typically from
3 to four
o'clock okay do you have any high
pressure
diabetes I did have diabetes but it's
gone
now okay are you taking supplements for
that uh no I'm not
okay he on the0 Doc huh he did say that
he's on the 90 program oh then you are
taking supplements well yeah I'm taking
the the uh plant derived minerals and
currently we have the uh
microbiome and we just got a box in
today for some other odds and an
okay do you have anything going on with
tonius any ringing in the ears I do have
tonius I was in Vietnam in the
1970s okay thank you for your service
thank you what branch of the service
were you in Air Force all right well I
retired as lieutenant colonel in the Air
Force so I left out of there as a staff
sergeant after six
years okay so um also do you have any
balance issues now now uh only since
I've uh I really not much but I do I am
careful to make sure I can hold on to
something just in case my knee or hip
collapses on me okay um let's see here
do you have anything going on with your
heart any your regular heart rate slow
heart rate fast heart rate I do I do
have taco
cardia you have tack cardia yeah I am
taking a product called soda law I think
originally it's called beta Pates
okay that when you have osteoprosis to
the skull and the skull is squeezing the
T cranial nerve you get stuff going on
with your heart you get py cardio which
is fast heart rate you get Brady cardio
which is slow heart rate you get
irregular heart rate which is called
atrial fibrillation and the doctors want
to treat all three of those as a heart
disease but all three of them are just
really osteoprosis of the skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve uhhuh
okay so here we go and I'm sure you're
already on the right track but for our
listeners at 270 pounds I want you get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no bar oats no buckwheat there's
no gluten in buckwheat but buckwheat
does has fago pyin which are 10 times
worse than
gluten um no sugar no carbonated drinks
even the diet drinks got to go and no
carbonated water because carbonation
neutralizes your stomach acid so you
cannot absorb minals or digest food now
at a 270 pounds I want you to have two
healthy brain and heart pack month two
healthy branded heart pack month that's
a full dose everything twice a day I
want you to take two biles a month of
our MSM so you can take three breakfast
St lunch dinner time they're going to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective C disc between vertebrae bone
makes bone cell um and so that's going
to help your immune system significantly
can make white blood cells and and also
um let's see here your antibodies
platelets red blood cells all all
because of you're putting the right
stuff in for your bone marrow
okay and the tentis sing in the ears
that will go away that's actually the
auditory branch of the at tral ner being
squeezed okay and so uh I would also
throw in one more thing well two things
number one for energy you want to use
the rebound or sport shrink has 100
nutrients in it Red Bull has one mineral
we have 75 minerals in ours and you do
want to watch the rebound I have the
sticks okay there's 30 of these sticks
in box we do have the canisters there's
36 servings in the canisters okay
rebound we do have the cans uh 12 oz
cans there's 12 cans in a case but the
cans are carbonated so what I like to do
because I like to drink some of those
cans so what I do is I pop the tops on
them before bedtime at night two of them
put them in the refrigerator so they're
flat in the morning all the carbonation
is gone I'll have one with breakfast
I'll have a half of the second one at
lunch I'll take the second half of the
second one over the afternoon so I have
that energy from those
75 minerals all day the energy is coming
from the minerals not from sugar and
caffeine like they do with Red Bull okay
so keep informed uh let us know what's
going on um by taking all these
nutrients you're going to eat less and
so you will um lose 20 30 40 50 pounds
if you need to okay keep in touch with
us every week or 10 days or two weeks or
whatever it is and we'll walk you
through this all right um see
you're bet
okay have a minute left
soesc let's go to Aaron Oh Aaron go
ahead and unmute
yourself sure so I've been on the 90
Essentials and just about every product
the youngevity takes for seven eight
months now okay I have never been able
to lose weight my entire life I don't
care you name a diet I've tried it uh um
I can't get blood sugar under control
and I can't get um into ketosis I
normally fast a minimum of 18 hours a
day I don't eat the bad foods um I'm
extremely careful when I eat organic you
name it I never eat let me let me
interrupt you there let me interrupt you
there how much you weigh sir uh 235
pounds okay do you have any hlid
pressure not normally now okay good um
let's see here
um okay and so your main complaints you
do have blood sugar problems okay I'm
taking a ton of the sweeties and vadium
and chromium okay what do you eat for
breakfast every morning I don't eat
breakfast I fast for a minimum of 18
hours a day so I don't eat till one
o'clock okay what do you eat uh normally
for lunch it'll be uh like a salad with
high fat uh some protein and that's it
and then uh dinner is usually a lot of
fat healthy fats and prot okay do you
ever eat any spaghetti or noodles or
anything like that no never
carbohydrates carbohydrates are kept to
minimum of under 50 grams a day okay so
no pancakes no waffles nope never no
pizza crust nothing no okay mystery is
how do you how is that possible so here
we go you're you're on the right track
so you want to get rid of all the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meat
no oils no glut weat R not no buckwheat
no sugar no carbonator drinks even the
diet drinks got to go and carbon water
at 235 PBS I would have you taking two
of the healthy brain and heart packs per
month okay full those thing twice a day
it's a healthy brain and heart pack that
has 215 nutrients okay 215 nutrients the
90 is the core and then we want you to
have two bottes a month for MSM very
important here take three at breakfast
three lunch dur dinner time and they're
going to support and promote Main a pair
of cartle ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the vertebrae bone
makes bone itself including the bone
marrows that can make white blood cells
and antibodies and platelets and red
blood cells because you do have kind of
a sugar problem off and on we do want
you to take our sweeties you go ahead
and take three of those um twice or
three times a day you'll find out which
is better for us turn out three twice a
day
um if you're on medications for blood
sugar issues don't um uh cold turkey off
of it but as your blood sugar comes into
the normal range you can go ahead and
start dropping off of it uh do you ever
get low BL s where you eat a big meal
and then half hour later hour later you
get
sleepy uh not normally no and I've been
taking all of those products for almost
eight months with no
changes okay good all right if you want
to lose some weight how tall are you
again 57 yeah 57 you could you could
lose 30 40 pounds and so what we do is
have one meal a day or keto KET Shake
our keto Shake comes in chocolate and
strawberry it's a meal replacer it's not
to be added to a meal it doesn't have to
be the same meal every day depending on
your schedule but um one keto shake a
day and you'll lose a half a pound or
two pounds a day and so you check
yourself on the scale every day and you
know kind of the same time every day and
you will before you go to bed whatever
and you will um see gosh I'm losing a
half a pound or a pound every day that's
good so if you want to lose 35 or 40
pounds you're looking at a month month
and a half okay you'll get down to where
you want to be and then you can start
you know adjusting Things based on where
you're at okay and so instead of having
a keto Shake every day one meal replacer
and remember it's a meal replacer it's
not to add to a meal it's a me replacer
but if let say instead of having one
meal every day a keto shake you might go
to when you get to where you want to be
try going dropping it down to a keto
Shake um once every three days instead
of every day but you got to wait until
you get down to where you want to be
okay you you'll love them they taste
good and again they're fun but again
they're a meal replacer they're not to
be added to a
meal yeah I've been following that
pretty closely and like I said I've been
taking all of the longevity products
from almost eight months no well but but
the keto Shake is designed to lose
weight it's got stuff in there right but
you have to so when you're doing a keto
diet Dr well you have to make sure that
you stay low on the carbohydrates
something that I'm sharing in the chat
is we have put together a proven plan
we've worked with one of the um leaders
in youngevity that has a masters in
nutrition we put together a keto game
plan so keto 90 game plan.com folks you
will be able to find an ebook that goes
through and it's a it's a proven plan
and it goes more than just the food
choices but it also goes into some mind
set things as well visit that and then
in that document there should be a link
to our Facebook group where we have a
support system for you where you can
bounce ideas off we also share some um
recipes and different ideas to help
create a more rounded more flavorful
keto diet because folks there's a
difference between going keto and having
it dirty keto and clean keto and when
you go clean keto with the 90 it's
GameChanger and that's why we've called
it keto 90 game plan so that's keto 90
game.com so Aon go ahead and check that
out join our group I look forward to see
you inside and also helping you reach
some break some plateaus and reach some
goals you don't lose weight or don't
have any changes then why would that be
is kind of the mystery so there's a d
digestive issue my friend we'll work
more on that digestive issue making sure
that you get that i26 in there are you
taking the
i26 no I've never heard of that yep so
i26 helps with eliminating any pathogens
that may be causing interruption in that
digestion so i26 folks it comes in
powder pills or powder chewables and
capsules so if you are not working with
a coach go to daily withd do.com you'll
find that in our store if you are
working with a coach make sure that you
get back with them and say Hey I want
some extra help with my
digestion I want some i26 and then let
them know the powder it's just one scoop
you mix it in about two three ounces of
water drink it and it tastes like the a
the pastry shell of any eclair without
the chocolate so it actually has has a
pleasant taste to it not overbearing um
but do not do not eat it within two
hours of eating eggs and do not mix it
with anything warm or hot because that
will denature the antibodies in the
i26 so just some little helpful hints
there on the i26 it's an amazing amazing
product Dr wck let's go over to a
question that came in on Facebook
actually a couple days ago that I
apologize Maran I we keep losing time so
I am going to be um asking a question Dr
wallik this woman is 34 years old 250
pounds 5 foot
five she has srin
syndrome and severe
allergies um and she's wanting to know
what is what she can do and it's sad to
say this woman Works in a medical office
she's a clinic supervisor um but she's
having problems with brittle nails gum
disease she's has pain in her back neck
and hips with excessive tooth decay she
has memory loss eyesight problems she
craves Foods Pride Foods uh dry eyes and
skin she's losing her hair
she has a slight heart issue that she is
controlled by medication uh she craves
sweets
carbohydrates uh she is very tired after
meals and she ex sweats excessively she
also has extreme allergies both food and
environmental with foot fungus
constipation and she takes fiber for
constipation so that trouble your cousin
uh not my cousin no that's an old that's
an old statement when somebody would
list 50 different diseases you say is
that all that's troubling your cousin
yep that's
it okay and so yeah this is very typical
of people with absorption problems
they're eating a lot of gluten weat b r
oats eat buckwheat they're getting the
fop pyin can't absorb stuff even if
they're supplementing and then um when
you have all these various
symptoms they on medication getting
sleepy after meals that's reactive
hypoglycemia okay all that kind of stuff
this is not difficult okay but uh we
need to be um forth right here and get
right down to it she weighs 250 pounds
she's 5'5 at 55 she should weigh 135
pounds so she needs to lose 100 pounds
okay so we wanted to have one uh keto
meal a day doesn't have to be the same
meal and it's when you add the keto
Shake um
it's it's the only meal you're going to
have okay you're not going to have
anything else at that meal okay you
don't want to add the keto shake to a
meal when you're want to lose weight you
have to take the keto shake and that's a
meal replacer okay not a not a meal like
a dessert or something like that okay
then I want so I wanted to have one meal
a day the keto shake and then had to be
the same meal every day and she'll begin
to lose almost immediately half a pound
of two pounds a day and then she needs
two healthy brain and heart pack for
months two healthy brain and heart pack
for month full twice a day then I want
her to have two botes a month of her MSM
thing take and that's for her skin and
her hair and all this other stuff want
her to her bone marrow white blood cells
platelets red blood
cells and I said sweeties for the for
the sleepiness right and when has sedes
okay and then we also want her to have
for the bone marrow okay again the um
MSM let's oh let's see here the
sleepiness we did that
um okay I think we're covering almost
everything here um the the carbohydrate
stuff when you're when you're taking all
these 90 essential nutrients in the
healthy brain and heart pack your
craving for carbohydrates kind of goes
away but she needs a sweeties to do with
the sleepiness because boy if she's
driving and she goes to sleep an hour
after she's eating lunch or something
like that that's dangerous so she needs
to be taking um two or three of our
sweeties okay twice a day okay and
that's going to help her level out her
blood sugar okay and then uh it doesn't
hurt to throw in the Hair Skin and Nails
take three of those twice a day there
two bottles a month they're little
bottles and they will help her with her
hair loss and skin issues and so forth
fingernails and toenails and all this
kind of stuff and I think that covers oh
I I do also want to have our rebound our
SP shrink okay with a 100 nutrients in
it 75 minerals and 25 vitamins amino
acids but I want her to use either the
sticks okay no carbonation or she can
use the canister no carbonation if she
uses the cans it's work because you got
to pop the tops on them at night put
them in the refrigerator so at night all
the gas is going out them all the
carbonation is going away so they're
flat in the morning okay and I I do both
you know I take the I take the canisters
I take the sticks I also use the cans
but I'm very very diligent of I don't
drink them I don't just pop them and
drink them I'll pop the tops on put
refrigerator tonight and drink them
tomorrow okay you gotta really pay
attention to that detail okay let's see
here with srin syndrome Dr wallik some
of the most common side effects happen
to be dry eyes dry mouth it affects
those glands that help control the
moisture what would you Rec okay well
again it's quote unquote an
autoimmune no no it's osteoprosis of the
skull okay squeezing the optic nerve the
optic artery and the optic vein okay
squeezing the the eth tral nerve you get
dizziness and tentis and ringing in the
ears and all that kind of stuff it
squeezes the optic nerve excuse me
olfactory nerve so you lose your sense
of smell um the heart the heart um
rhythm is all messed up well that's
because of squeezing the tenth cral
nerve the Vegas nerve the skull is busy
there squeezing all these things and so
that's why
the um MSM the healthy brain and heart
pack doesn't hurt to throw in the
collagen peptides scoop of that with the
morning drinks the evening drink and
don't forget the rebound enormous amount
of minerals and the rebound 75 minerals
which helps rebuild the skull and all
the bones and the vertebra in the back
and the shoulders and the hips and the
knees and all this kind of stuff all
right well we have about seven minutes
Dr W let's try to get two more questions
in here and let go to Jill Jill go ahead
and unmute
yourself hello there thank you for
taking my call I have two questions but
I think they'll be shorter ones they are
both on uh animal not on
human um I have someone who is an owner
of a six-year-old scottishfold
cat and she says that she's looking for
something to help her cat because that
breed is prone to arthritis and spinal
issues and she was inquiring whether
we we had a something do you know how
much I can't ra you know how much the
cat weighs oh that was a mistake I did
not ask I'm sorry do okay all right so
let's just go three to five pounds which
is common for a cat okay unless it's a
lion we go 400 pounds but okay okay so
needs a good brand of canned cat food
with vitamins minerals added to it okay
not just a can of tuna or table scraps
or stuff like that good can of cat food
with vitamins minerals and follow the
label for direction and amounts and then
we also want that cat um to have a half
a scoop okay of the arthr deex half a
scoop of arthr deex cats love it because
it's got fish liers in there they they
love it okay that's that's that's a
major major major supplement program for
cats and dogs and even Birds okay so go
that direction what's the second
one uh the second one is uh a dog well I
hear a lot of different dogs who have
problems with their an glands and that
they have to be
expressed and um someone came in today
and asked me about that that her dog has
this problem what can they do okay well
I go again with a good can of dog food
canned dog food with all the vitamin
minerals in it um per 20 pounds of body
weight is one scoop of the
arthr and a lot of times uh the the anal
gland thing can be due to a back issue
squeezing nerves okay and control the
glands and so this is why you want that
arthr deex um and let's go there and it
wouldn't hurt to put a dish of that's
going to be the source of water for this
dog and the cat both of them put uh an
ounce of our plant liquid plant Metals
per quart of water an ounce of the plant
metal per quart of water put in that
dish and some of them will walk away
from it for a while but after a day or
two they're going to get thirsty and
they'll drink it okay if they don't like
it with one ounce per quart go to a half
half an ounce for quart but they need
those minerals tone up the muscles on
both ends the mouth and the in the anal
area but U this is easily resolved okay
thank you doc you bet thank
you for one more yep let's go up to
Walter go ahead and unmute yourself
Walter hey can you hear me yes sir okay
I'm calling for my dad who lives in
Germany he's a 6'4 210 pounds and 83
years
old um this is for his medical history
he had kidney stones before he's a
pre-diabetic he has heart problems and
he he had a pacemaker attached to him
and he's currently in hospital with
they're saying
hemorrhoids um from what I remember I
don't live there I live in the United
States now so um from what I remember
he's uh he's of sleepy and takes a lot
of
naps and um he I know he's on at least
five different meds right now okay so
here we go he's got to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no R oats no buckwheat no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the dot drinks
and the carbonated water got to go and
then 210 pounds I want to have two
healthy brain and heart packs we ship to
Germany with warehouses in Europe and
all of stuff and so they can help you
get all this done um he needs two of the
healthand heart packs per month full
those twice a day he needs MSM two
botles a month take three breakfast stre
lunch dinner do with all his joints and
bones and stuff and then he also needs
the collagen peptides to scuba that with
his morning drink SC his evening drink
and for um his heart wanted to have the
cardio effects cardio effect you can
have two doses a day of the cardio
effect if he's sleepy all the time he
may be having reactive hypoglycemia low
blood sugar so he doesn't need the
sweeties take um three of those twice a
day and see if that doesn't help okay
and when it comes to the hemorrhoids I
see here he said a kidney issue okay is
he on
dialysis no I don't think so
okay he also needs the ultimate daily
classic tablets he could take three of
those price a day it's two bottes a
month the ultimate daily classic support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in the brain the heart and the
kidneys okay and the kidneys when those
arteries get blocked in the kidneys they
put out a hormone to drive the blood
pressure up to try and get more blood
into the kidneys to filter that's this
job okay and so that's all this is all
resolvable this is all stuff that goes
along with nutritional
deficiencies and at his age it's not
unusual for people as they get older
they start Contracting on what they eat
and they're eating very small
variety of food and they're not taking
lots of vitamins and minerals and stuff
and so their nutrition is kind of
spiraling downward as a result okay and
so this is easily resolved but he's
going to have to somebody's gonna have
to make sure he's getting all these
nutrients and taking them say I'm
84 right I know yeah and most people
think I'm in my 50s okay because of my
energy levels and that kind of stuff and
my my physical looks and everything
um and so your dad can do this it'll
take him a couple of months to get there
but he somebody's going to have to coach
him and make sure he's getting
everything he need you leave it to him
he's not to change his way I'm gonna try
to help because I'm really health
conscious person you know too um I do
know he likes a lot of bread and cereal
and well there you go that's gluten he's
definitely using vegetable oils too and
I think I think he likes to drink
carbonated water a lot of people in
Europe like carbonated water so I know
yeah that's
yeah so I don't do that but I know he
he's been doing that and uh he does like
supplements so I think I I can get him
on board with switching from meds to the
supplements making it making a what
transition very good Walter sounds like
he's got a great son so stand strong you
can do it and thank you so much for
coming on on behalf of your father and
asking questions
yeah keep us ined because a lot of 80
year olds out there want to know what's
going on so keep us ined walk you
through this thank
you all right now Dr wck it is nine
minutes till the hour do you have a
quick uh thought on what about pools and
they have chlorine and public pools I
mean people love to go swimming Dr wck
especially in this heat all right well
again chlorine is an essential nutrient
okay as long as you don't abuse it like
everything else okay um so chlorine in
the swimming pool you don't want to be
sitting in the swimming pool for three
hours okay um what you want to do is um
you say okay I'm G to take 10 15 minutes
in the middle of the day when it's hot
okay you know hit the pool and that's
where you want to go you don't want to
be sitting in the pool for an hour two
three hours a day or an hour three times
a day don't do that okay and on the
cooler days you're better off because
the chlorine is quiet on the hot days
the chlorine turns gaseous okay smell it
on those hot days yeah you can smell it
yeah and that's on the hot days okay it
goes out of solution into the gases and
it that becomes problematic so on the on
the cooler days even though the water
may
be not as warm as you'd like it but it's
safer all right well thank you so much
Dr wallik another day well spent with
you thank you for the information and
getting some new questions new people I
love it Dr Wall have a great rest of
your day thank you thank you and to
everybody let's hear from you on a
regular basis God bless you I know he
loves you bye bye God bless you doc all
right if I could get my co-hosts on with
me I would greatly appreciate it and
there was a question about using soap
Yes it's okay to use soap but you
definitely want to make sure that you
look at the ingredients
and as a soap maker myself yes it does
require oils but folks they go through a
saponification process that takes out a
lot of those harmful antioxidants that
are are not antioxidants
oxidation that creates problems within
the body so make sure that you have one
that's full of fat home I love
personally love the soap that do that
youngevity
offers um because we have a couple
different off options with our Beauty
Bar and then also we have one that has
lavender and tea tree and it just feels
great on the skin so there's a quick
little answer to that and I just want to
thank my co-hosts um we are growing
folks I have I have a huge team and
there are some people that have the the
ability the time the desire to step up
and help put on a program like this that
are already working their businesses
because they have that passion to help
people and if you were invited by
somebody to watch this program make sure
that you get back with them they cared
enough to make sure that you had
information that empowers you to take
control of your health folks if you're
hurting there's a reason why let's
address that underlying cause instead of
just mask the symptoms and I have with
me today uh Ruth Ellen Sanchez who is is
my uh executive production manager she
helps me organize everything we get
everything set up in place she has done
a great job training AJ who brings in
another speal set of skills that is like
blowing social media up and all of the
different platforms so we are super
thankful and happy to have him on board
with us as well we have Phyllis who has
been with Dr wallik for well since the
beginning folks and her and her husband
were very instrumental in getting Dr
wallik on the radio in the beginning and
getting his program syndicated well now
she's helping us on the digital end of
it and going even bigger and broader
than radio and the AM FM waves where we
are
using what would it be called internet
waves um to go even farther beyond our
borders of and Beyond where those uh
previous waves reached and then we also
have Marilyn which in the beginning I
told you you want to make sure that you
you know have that chat open because she
puts a wealth of information in there
and yeah she she's fingers she's she's
got magic fingers there um and I Phyllis
she does too so the two of them do a
little bit of tag teaming and fill in
for each other and we have sherry
another amazing coach who is okay there
are no
small jobs in this production okay so
where she thinks that maybe just letting
people in her and Albert both um letting
people in watching
cameras folks it's required otherwise
you guys wouldn't be in the room with us
to watch so I just want to do a special
shout out to them as well because that
is such an important job and we have
added Albert to the team here as he is
always showing up and he is building a
business in South Africa reaching
Beyond places that you know it's not
many people are are on the youngevity
products there folks and if you live in
an area where you've never heard of
youngevity before then this might be the
reason why you are watching this program
so make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this program with you
or if there's nobody to thank go to
daily withth
do.com use that contact us and for
everybody we have a newsletter make sure
that you're signed up for it you are
able to submit questions through that
sign up and let us know if you are
working with somebody if you're on
products what your questions are or if
you you know need a little help tweaking
what you're on to help you reach your
goals that's what we are here for and
then we also have Coach Rod coach Rod
coming with us from uh
Sports AJ's going like this um from
uh Sports and um well he he's got a lot
of background folks and a lot of lot of
skills techniques knowledge that he is
bringing to us so I look forward to some
shows that he will be doing and
presenting to our audience and also he
and AJ doing in the near
future and providing a little bit of
variety and and mixing it up a little
bit folks because we want to meet
everybody where they're at and these
guys are hilarious just for warning so
thank you coach rod for being part of
this team also and um also being out
there in the different platforms and
filling questions as they coming in and
having that interaction with people
because folks we're not a bot we're real
people we're really here and we're
really here to help you so get back with
the person that shared this program with
you and remember Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12:50 pm. Pacific time that's
like almost midnight for Albert soon um
so we're here
247 you can plug into us on YouTube
Rumble Facebook Instagram
Twitter uh we're getting on brighty on
where those have to be manually loaded
and
also patreon gotta manually load those
but folks we're getting we're getting
the message out there
and we do it more efficiently when you
help us and share the message so share
the message and be part
of the team so that you also can have
that that feeling of how awesome it is
is to have people
like the person that was in that case
study reach out and say I no longer have
those
symptoms and she was only on the program
two and a half months
folks it's possible and it happens each
and every day so let us hear your
story again use that contact us on daily
with.com and until next time bye for
[Music]
now